vinnie d'agostino
our buddy former fbi agent we know
vinnie a long time promoting his podcast
vinnie's proof of work
and um
it's a show where he can share his
thoughts and experiences on bitcoin law
cyber crime stand up and uh the
government and current events hey buddy
good to see you
i am it's funny man we were talking
about bitcoin before and how of course i
i bought in late and it's just dead now
yeah
we've lost yeah is there any shot it's
going to come back and be worth money
again every shot everybody feels like
you're in late i got in at 60 bucks and
i was convinced we we missed it i was
sitting at the fbi in the squad area
and because we were wearing 60 bucks
yeah we were wearing around 10 bucks and
we were all we're gonna buy a bitcoin
miner and and like share the profits
uh and then quit our government jobs and
be gazillionaires but we literally said
well you know it's we probably missed
the boat at 60. sorry i hope you i hope
you bought just
one i started mining early i started
doing mining from home because uh did
you have to get a computer like just for
mining yeah it looks like a giant uh vcr
from you know 70s and 80s it was big
back then they were monsterous and i
plugged it into one into my
tv room and one into the garage and they
they use a tremendous amount of
electricity and they kick off a
tremendous amount of heat so within i
don't know uh julie's with me today
probably within a month uh my wife said
get that [ __ ] thing out of the house
it's 110 degrees the cats were like
having heat strokes because we'd lock
the cats in the back room it was way too
hot so everything moved to the garage
and you're trying to explain to her this
is our financial future she's like what
are you talking about and this was 2012
so nobody really was talking about
outside of the the community itself
trying to explain bitcoin to anyone my
wife or my neighbors it was like you
just might as well just say it's magic
money right yeah but i was only making
like 10 bucks a day in profit
but and i was using about 10 bucks a day
consuming about 10 bucks a day in
electricity so i wasn't making any money
but i believed it would be worth a lot
more so i went back when bitcoin hit 69
000 and i redid the math i was making
about fifteen thousand dollars a day
from my garage
if if i had kept all of it i didn't keep
all of it i foolishly like a lot of
people sold some of it when i thought
it's never gonna go higher you kept some
yeah but i wish i had sold all of it at
69 000. i know yeah that's the that's
the thing with bitcoin it it's it's like
a it's like a marriage you when you buy
bitcoin it's for better or worse uh and
so you have to commit i tell people
think two years ahead three years ahead
and i would guarantee that it's going to
be worth a tremendous tremendous amount
more than it is now but when people buy
it and they're looking to like the day
the day-to-day and get out of it in two
months and make money it's it's there's
tons of [ __ ] coins you could buy to do
that go right doge and you know spin the
roulette wheel you'll make money
bitcoin's not like that was there
anything more satisfying than elon musk
doing snl and all the [ __ ] idiots
that bought a whole bunch of doge right
before thinking that like okay he's
gonna get on tv he's gonna say it it's
to skyrocket we'll all be millionaires
and doge just like
it's like during the bit yeah in his
sketch [ __ ] the bed yeah i was i
remember i was literally watching the
chart now it was a little bit satisfying
it's nothing against people that are
into altcoins it's just that bitcoins
the fundamentals of bitcoin are so
much better they're so
much more robust the security features
around it that there really is bitcoin
and then crypto when people say get into
crypto i always try to correct them it's
like there's bitcoin and there's crypto
if you're gonna get into crypto that's
fine that's there's about 17 000 other
cryptos out there you can get into but
as far as the fundamentals and where the
institutional money where the
governments are going to go to it's
going to be bitcoin because it's the
most decentralized it's the most secure
it's where
people say don't you worry if i have my
life savings in bitcoin i sleep fine at
night i don't worry really at all yeah i
don't worry about i worry more and what
happened in canada should have been a
wake-up call for a lot of people i would
worry more about having that amount of
money in a traditional
banking account than i would in bitcoin
honey you're dangerous you're like
talking to you i'm oh i swear like
months i'm like i'm out of crypto this
is so stupid i'm done with bitcoin nfts
are garbage like this
and like i'm sitting here having one
conversation with you and literally in
my head i'm going like yeah i need to
put more money in this right now just
buy a little each week and but you got
to just forget about it you can't like
that insurance commercial it's never
much just what's left after i break a
dollar yeah a little yeah
change jar yup i mean i uh you know you
don't need it's going to get to the
point in five ten years
there's only going to be a handful of
people on the planet who own like one
bitcoin it's all going to be measured in
satoshi so there's a hundred million
satoshi's in every bitcoin yeah and
that's the divisibility is important
because you need to be able to buy a
pack of gum or something with it uh and
so
my prediction is you know five ten years
it's gonna be you know how many how many
sats do you have what how many satoshi's
do you have and you know people who have
a bitcoin are going to be the you know
elite amongst the elite who have like
yeah i know a guy who owns a bitcoin or
two bitcoin there's only 21 million
bitcoin that's it right yeah there's
something like
50
something millionaire 50 something
millionaires in the united states alone
i think so think about that every
millionaire in this country if they just
wanted one they can't get one is that a
weird thing to think about that's crazy
so when people start to really rush
towards this and the institutional money
starts to really flow into it there's
going to be that parabolic you know
you're going to see that 69k is going to
look like nothing it might take five
years because everything going on in the
world
i mean satoshi the guy who created
bitcoin didn't anticipate covet he
didn't anticipate
you know
not directly he didn't anticipate the
collapse of of you know uh
of of the of the country in so many
different ways with you know the ukraine
and everything so who knows how that's
affecting it and where we would be but
it's pretty remarkable i also here's why
i worry about bitcoin because i think
people couple bitcoin and and like nfts
and crypto and everything all together
and i feel like there's a lot of people
myself included that are completely
losing faith not in the technology
behind nft and the blockchain but the
practical application of it because of
how ridiculous all these celebrity
nonsense boring stuff is
that it makes me feel like people are
gonna couple that with bitcoin and i
feel like the celebrities are ruining it
yep i i i i wonder sometimes there's i
don't know 15 000 plus different cryptos
and i wonder if that market cap
all went into bitcoin the price it would
be at would be astronomical
unfortunately it's going to take people
years to realize that all those altcoins
and [ __ ] coins that are out there are
going to lead them back to bitcoin
eventually it's just going to take time
how about ethereum
so here's my take on ethereum the
fundamentals of ethereum suck they've
been working on an update for ethereum
for like six years i own some of it
because i think it's got good brand uh
recognition because look you're asking
me about it right um and out of all the
cryptos out there right there's bitcoin
and ethereum and doge are probably the
three most with brand recognition but to
be completely honest i just don't have
any confidence there is a there's a
leader behind ethereum this guy vitalik
and i hate that bitcoin has no leader
it's it's it's
um the importance for that is as we know
in
where we are right now as a society i
don't want to find out that the leader
of ethereum is caught with like three
dead kids in his trunk like i don't want
my life savings tied to a dude that
could be running a you know a a
pedophile ring for all you know every
all faith is lost in it you've lost
everything or he's just not like
perceived as woke enough or he's just
not this or he's not that so the fact
that satoshi invented bitcoin and then i
think got back in his time machine and
went back to the future and left it for
the world i love it because there's no
one to smash there's no one to go after
and there's nobody um that can change
the rules of bitcoin whereas ethereum it
doesn't have a brand
yeah you know there's no central figure
exactly it's completely decentralized
there is no the
the thing behind bitcoin is the rules um
cannot be changed ethereum
they've been changing the rules since
inception and why would i want um why
would i want something that someone
could change the rules that adversely
affects
what it's worth
which is what the government is right
the government changes the rules when
they print a trillion dollars of cash i
didn't vote on that you didn't vote on
that but what that means is every dollar
in your bank account is now worth less
through nothing you did you didn't you
didn't do anything wrong you're saving
for your future and the government's
like
let's just print another trillion
dollars create this inflate
hyperinflation and then everyone else
eats it even though they're not
realizing they're eating it with bitcoin
the fact that there's only 21 million
and that will never change it cannot be
changed that's hard-coded into the
network i like that because i know that
well logically it's going to just keep
going up because it's anti-inflationary
because there's going to be a cap of 21
million bitcoin that will never be but
aren't bitcoin aren't they gonna not
finish being mined for like another
hundred years 2140 is when it'll finish
and that's the point of it is that
satoshi predicted that every four years
is a having event where every four years
half the amount of bitcoin available
when you're mining bitcoin
the reward it's called this is cut in
half and it's brilliant because every
four years if you look at the chart
every four years
in and around those having events when
people go wow if i mine bitcoin i'm
getting only half of what i was getting
before the price skyrockets up so
initially when you were mining bitcoin
and you discovered what's called a block
you were awarded 50 bitcoin
which sounds outrageous today right yeah
but when when it was worth less than a
penny
it was like who cares so that guy who
said i've mined six like i said on one
of the posts i mined 600 bitcoin in the
last week but i feel like i missed the
boat
he was making it was only a couple bucks
you know back then this 2011. but as the
price of bitcoin goes up the reward
could go down because now if you're
rewarded um
uh we're down to
six is it six bitcoin 6.25 whatever
number we're at and i'm drawing a blank
um that's still an incredible amount of
money that if you
mine bitcoin you'll be rewarded enough
to justify the elect use of electricity
for it and that's how it's created
because the electricity being used in
the mining protects the network so he
figured out a way to incentivize it to
say brilliant how do we protect the
network and pay people
money to do so so it encourages vinnie
in long island to mine in from his
garage but also uh make it so that the
amount that being rewarded isn't too
much or too little right and that's
where it's been is that the incentive
has been perfectly aligned all along
that the more people
uh mine and and the more people like
when i was mining the first thing i
after i got my first electric bill it
was like a thousand dollars i said i
have to figure out a way
to mine more efficiently so
when it got cold i started heating my
house with the heat from the miner
that's hilarious and this is how yeah
but it it seemed weird at the time and
now in hindsight i'm like no this was
the intention because now look at the
world they're going to be mining bitcoin
using the exhaust from volcanoes in el
salvador because they're like it's free
heat that can run turbines that can
generate electricity but i just love
that that's how it ain't you are i heat
my house with this [ __ ] okay like that's
how it is yeah oh yeah you are it
becomes an obsession i had it connected
i had 3d printed these little exhaust um
pieces of plastic that you screwed onto
the back of the miner and then that was
connected to the ducks in my house the
hvac duct so in the crawl spaces in the
house and in the attic there was miners
running and it's freezing in the attics
and crawl spaces so that's good because
it keeps the machines cold but all the
hot air was being pumped through
the house so my heating bill went down
tremendously but then in the summertime
i was sol because i was trying to figure
out a way to heat my pool with it but
you really need to get like super
creative to do that but you can do it
but if i could rebuild a pool tomorrow i
would absolutely leave a spot under the
pool for mining equipment and just load
it up with bitcoin monitors and have
like a 89 90 degree pool year round you
know but that's what people are doing
they're moving their bitcoin mining
farms to places around the world where
it's green where it's using reusable
energy so it's actually going to be good
for the environment so this the scarcity
is guaranteed in bitcoin
the only thing that's not guaranteed is
people's faith in it right like they're
you that's the oh that's that's the risk
right the people
whether it's because of all the weird
nft stuff or because of whatever it is
they get scared because it dips
like if people lose faith in it then the
scarcity if enough people lose faith in
it then the scarcity doesn't matter and
that's true of fiat currency that's true
of the the magic money we have in our
pocket that we all have faith in that's
not backed by gold anymore that's backed
by a government that's just printing
money like toilet paper yes people start
to lose faith in that around the world
the vision is and what we're happy
seeing happening is they're going to be
drawn to bitcoin because they're going
to say we've lost faith we've cons lost
confidence in our governments to protect
the value of the money so now we're
going to put confidence in mathematics
and encryption which can't screw you
over and we're going to slowly exchange
our fiat for bitcoin and that's the
projection that people like me see is
going to happen yeah like for me that's
where i'm at i'm like because i i
i see the potential in bitcoin really
revolving around how many people have
are losing faith in governments all
around the world and and exponentially
really and then i get worried because
celebrities [ __ ] things up and i feel
like those two forces are what are you
know kind of coming at each other well
it's like i always say we're slave to
the almighty buck
i mean if there was ever a bow to put on
this conversation that was incredible
to the almighty buck uh vinnie
d'agostino it's i mean it's always great
having you in yeah
vinnie's proof of work podcast uh is out
there uh i'm sure that everybody's got
questions and i'm sure that that people
would listen to you talk about this for
hours and hours which is why it's good
that the podcast exists you can go to
vinnie dagostino.com
uh or at proof of work one you can
follow vinnie on twitter at
proof of work one